gaul was queen
and ryan was [ __ ]
dwayne said ryan's nickname was [ __ ]
oh that's a yeah that's sort of it's not
too dissimilar at home
what were your co-stars most annoying
habits on set
just one
i would definitely say that gal and
dwayne's most annoying habits on set
were being adorable
they were both adorable constantly and
it was disgusting
gull
most annoying habit
she's perfect
ryan's most annoying habit
any time he breathed
[Laughter]
what is your best party trick
i show everybody how i can pick up a
grape
not using my hands not using my mouth
not using my feet not using my knees or
my elbows
well i'll show you later back
wait my wife is going to see this i
think
[Laughter]
best party trick
oh my god vanishing i can get out of a
party when no one will notice my
nickname as a kid was casper like casper
the ghost because i would just vanish
we call it the canadian exit
did you have nicknames for each other on
set
dwayne has enough names right i mean the
rock dj
dwayne
maui uh yes gaul was queen
and ryan was [ __ ]
dwayne said ryan's nickname was [ __ ]
oh that's a yeah that's sort of it's not
too dissimilar at home
honestly i want to be humble but they
call me um yeah uh your highness
the one and only queen of them all of
the universe
[Laughter]
what is your go-to karaoke
um hold on by wilson phillips
i know that there is pain
but you
hold on for one more day and you
break free yeah there you go i don't
know if it ever charted but it's a song
from uh george michael um oh
kissing a fool but remember this every
other kiss that you ever give long as we
both live when you need a hand of
another man one you really i'm running
out of breath it's in hebrew
and it's like uh super fast
it's called cats
um
yeah i can go on and on
who would win in a fight between you
three
myself gallagher that's a good question
uh i will avoid a fight at all costs
i think dwayne on sheer strength but you
know we're fast we can get away so if
you piss them off all you got to do is
walk quickly away and you'll be fine uh
gal is very flexible and stretchy and
you know i think was in the military i
would not mess with her so i'm going to
say gal
easily
gaul would mop the floor with my ass and
with ryan's ass ryan will run fast dj
will be a gentleman and he'll stay but
he'll never do anything to me and then i
go in for an attack killer punch
who's the biggest joker out of you three
um
probably me
ryan
it's just good with comedy i'm gonna say
gaal actually joked around the most i
joke around like when we're rolling but
gal like just never stops she just like
gets the giggles
and it gets and it's infectious then
suddenly everyone has the giggles and
then you suddenly realize it's you've
been giggling in so long it's now the
next olympics
thank you so much
appreciate it thank you appreciate it
thank you thank you it's good to see you
as always bye-bye
i love lad bible here we go
you don't like gloves don't love gloves
worming your hand into a glove i'm just
like ha ha i don't like it but wait did
you wear gloves with mary poppins didn't
you yeah and it was tough it was tough
i'm not gonna lie i took them off
whenever i could really was it tough it
was really
tough for you it's really tough for me
it was really hard really hard you
should toughen up